[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour respirer
n'hésitez pas je peux vous demander de
rester en apnée pendant 18 minutes un
rassurez vous donc commencer par bien
vous ventilé vous installer
confortablement
alors je suis venu vous parler d'apnée
mais tout le monde connaît ce sport j'ai
pas besoin de vous de vous faire lever
la main j'en suis persuadé alors
pourquoi en grande partie grâce aux
grâce au film le grand bleu de luc
besson sorti en 1988 qui retrace
l'épopée de jacques mayol et enzo
maiorca ces deux pionniers de la plaine
sportive moderne
alors l'homme plonge en apnée depuis des
milliers d'années pour se nourrir ou
pour faire du commerce c'est ce qu'on
appelle la vivrières mais c'est vraiment
une une pratique à distinguer de la
presse sportive moderne d'aujourd'hui
ont donc qui est plus quelque chose qui
s'apparente n une discipline bien naître
entre guillemets comme comme le yoga par
exemple la méditation en plus d'être un
sport évidemment extrême alors le grand
bleu ces films je suis je suis
évidemment ravi de ravi de pouvoir lui
rendre hommage aujourd'hui j'adore ce
film m'a beaucoup marqué et les
plongeurs d'aujourd'hui et d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs son sont bien
loin des clichés de plongeurs suicidaire
véhicule et un petit peu par le film
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt des des gens
totalement conscient de même accroché à
la vie et qui aiment respirer rassurez
vous alors j'adore l'apnée depuis depuis
tout gosse
j'adore plongée en apnée je suis
vraiment attiré sous la surface
ce soit en vacances en mer ou à la
piscine ou dans la baignoire jeudi rejet
j'ai toujours adoré ça j'ai vu le film
évidemment
évidemment le grand bleu qui m'a
beaucoup marqué à l'âge de 10-12 ans et
cet état d'esprit un petit peu un petit
peu rêveur un petit peu aventurier un
petit peu détaché comme ça de la réalité
un petit peu aventurier ma mamma
vraiment collé à la peau tout au long de
de mon adolescence jusqu'à mes études
d'ingénieur du son en région parisienne
et la suite de ses études j'étais dans
un quotidien citadins somme toute assez
assez morose à c'est assez stressant
assez déprimant je sentais que j'étais
pas du tout à ma place en fait qu'il
manquait réellement quelque chose
n'avait pas du tout trouvé ma vocation
réalité et c'est par le sport que je me
suis sorti de 2,7 de cette routine
citadine j'ai commencé à nager parce que
j'adore ça évidemment et en cherchant un
club de natation sur internet
ma recherche comme ça a dévié vers la
paix je me suis dit tiens j'adore
j'adore l'apnée est ce que ça exige je
savais même pas en fait si ça existait
ou pas la majorité d'entre vous un peu
ici j'imagine et donc j'ai tapé club
d'apnée paris sur google et puis là je
me suis rendu compte qu'on était des
dizaines de milliers en fait à
s'intéresser à ce passionné réellement
pour ce sport je vais me rendue compte
d'ailleurs que c'était un sport à
l'occasion en pleine expansion et qui
avait même plus une piscine municipale
en france qui n'a pas son club d'apnée
en pratique aujourd'hui l'apnée ans
gilles ou en région de brest à nice en
piscine comme d'ailleurs en mer
évidemment et donc je j'ai appelé comme
ça les clubs date mais ce jour là les
uns après les autres jusqu'à en trouver
un qui est qui qui m'accepte dans lequel
il restait il restait une place
c'était ma passion donc là bas mon
travail depuis 2011
et j'ai été pour faire un baptême
d'apnée on appelle ça comme ça comme un
baptême de plongée sous marine et un
baptême pour moi au double sens du terme
en réalité déjà je découvrais une sports
la plongée en apnée
mais c'était vraiment un baptême pour
moi car je découvrais aussi une nouvelle
vie je me lancer dans quelque chose de
nouveau et je trouvais réellement ma
vocation
qu est ce qui a fait que je suis
qui je suis d'ailleurs aujourd'hui j'ai
commencé une année d'apnée découverte
date n'est plaisir on appelle ça comme
ça et la deuxième année je me suis je me
suis mis à faire de la compétition et de
compétition en compétition comme ça je
suis arrivé aux championnats de france
où j'ai été recruté par les
sélectionneurs de l'équipe de france et
je suis parti à kazan en russie en
russie au championnat du monde d'apnée
et pour la première fois en 2013 depuis
deux ans après avoir après avoir
commencé ce sport je devenais champion
du monde pour la pour la première fois
en 2013 alors il ya différentes
disciplines dont la pne sportives
modernes
on connaît aujourd'hui outre la chasse
sous-marine évidemment qui se fait en la
paix mais aussi tout le monde connaît la
profondeur honorer cette image de
plongeurs qui descendre dans le bleu des
abysses comme ça je peux comme sûres
comme sur la photo dr mais il existe
aussi d'autres d'autres disciplines
en pratique aujourd'hui en intérieur on
dort on appelle ça la mine d'or c'est un
peu ce que je vous ai expliqué avant
c'est ma spécialité le but étant de
nager à l'horizontale le plus longtemps
possible le plus loin possible en apnée
avec ce genre d'outil une monopalme on
sent pas le dr et certains athlètes de
temps en temps tente aussi des records
un petit peu farfelue alors certains
plongent dans des ses notes vous savez
ces trous d'eau un petit peu qu'on
trouve son sens les formations calcaires
dans la jungle amazonienne
certains plongeant en rivière dans des
dans des galeries immergé même fond de
l'aspect l'eau en apnée
certains plongent dans des lacs et
parfois même en laque en lac gelé et
c'est mon dernier record du monde en
date
j'ai été en finlande sous la glace d'un
lac gelé
battre un record un record d'apnée en
distance sous la glace pour le coup le
but étant d'aller le plus loin possible
à l'horizontale sous la glace dans une
eau gelée et voilà voilà à quoi ça
ressemble
je mène aussi
[Musique]
2 minutes et 38 secondes plus tard
bonjour sort 175 m
record battu
[Musique]
j'ai déjà en tête mon prochain challenge
alors ce que vous avez vu la et un court
extrait du de mon premier film impôts et
rex qui est un 70 minutes
il sortira en septembre si tout va bien
qui revient sur les deux dernières
années de préparation pour mes deux
derniers records du monde y compris ce
record ce record sous glace la plaie est
une discipline avant tout mental c'est
un sport qui est à 90% mentale avant de
notre physique et c'est le seul sport
à ma connaissance à seule discipline qui
imposa son pratiquant un de dépasser un
réflexe de survie primaire très ancrée
qu'est la ventilation et ça c'est très
particulier c'est très particulier on
s'est rendu compte que ça ça impacte est
profondément le le plongeur au niveau de
son équilibre psychique de la gestion du
stress de ses émotions
je vais me procurer une meilleure
confiance en lui las une meilleure
conscience de lui et donc des autres
aussi et directement et de
l'environnement de son environnement du
monde dans lequel il vit c'est pour
partager ça que je suis là en réalité
aujourd'hui devant vous c'est parce que
j'ai l'intimé conviction que il est
possible pour tout le monde tout un
chacun avec ses outils son propre
terrain de jeu d'accéder à une certaine
forme de réalisation de soi de
concrétisation de soi par le dépassement
de soi qu'ils soient mentale mental ou
physique
d'ailleurs pour moi ça s'est fait avec
la pratique un sport extrême à haut
niveau
l'apnée mêlant pourquoi la tenue
pourquoi ce sport ça peut paraître
dangereux contre intuitif contre naturel
inutile même pour certains mais
justement justement tout et tout et là
je vous expliquais d'abord d'abord
saint-jacques demain évidemment qu'il
n'a jamais qui n'a jamais essayé de
retenir sa respiration pour un caprice
ou entre copains évidemment au collège
au lycée
donc il ya quelque chose de très très
amusant là dedans c'est un jeu c'est
très compétitif
au-delà de ça plusieurs choses d'abord
le béaba de l'apnée comme dans bien
d'autres disciplines bien-être entre
guillemets comme le yoga ou la
méditation par exemple la maîtrise de la
ventilation et est primordiale et c'est
une des premières choses qu'on apprend
on appelait ça bien se ventiler comme
dirait mon collègue plongeurs et
camarades guillaume néry que certains
connaissent peut-être apprendre à ne pas
respirer c'est en réalité apprendre à
bien respirer c'est paradoxal mais
pourtant c'est la vérité
on apprend à se servir de son diaphragme
apprend à assouplir sa sphère thoracique
à utiliser totalement son volume
pulmonaire et rien que ça ça a déjà un
énorme impact d'ailleurs je vous invite
tous un jour essayer techniques de base
vraiment on apprend en apnée dans
d'autres disciplines la respiration
ventrale donc une main sur le ventre
une main sur le thorax tout simplement
il n'y a que la main sur le ventre qui
doit bouger
[Rires]
ça peut paraître compliqué mais ça vient
avec un petit peu d'entraînement bien
sûr et pratique et ça comme ça cinq
minutes avant votre prochain événement
stressant comme je les fait par exemple
avant de descendre sur cette scène et je
vous assure que votre votre prochain
rendez vous chez votre patron pour votre
augmentation se passera mieux que
d'habitude
alors depuis des années depuis les
années 60 70 depuis l'épopée en fait de
maillots les meilleurs cas les médecins
n'ont de cesse de dire en fait qu'on ne
descendra jamais plus profond que telle
profondeur
on n'ira jamais plus loin que telle
distance en apnée ou qu'on ne reviendra
jamais sa respiration plus longtemps que
telle durée est en fait les plongeurs
n'ont eu de cesse de leur démontrer
qu'en fait que le corps humain est une
formidable machine d'adaptation à son
environnement
en réalité et on a ça en commun avec nos
cousins les mammifères marins
ça va être là le corps de mon
intervention
on s'est rendu compte qu'on était à tel
point adapté que c'était carrément ancré
en nous dans notre patrimoine génétique
et ont comme jeudi on a ça en commun
être les meilleurs dans ce qui prouve
que quelque part avant peut-être qu'on
vivait il ya de ça un certain nombre de
millions d'années sous la surface nous
aussi comme des mammifères marins
ces fameuses adaptation physiologique ce
sont les réflexes d'immersion diving
réflexe en anglais c'est l'outil de
travail principale des apnéistes avec
l'annonciation
ce sont des mécanismes d'adaptation au
milieu le plus connu d'entre eux la
bradycardie subaquatique hop c'est aller
trop vite
mon coeur quand je suis en apnée veut le
rythme cardiaque de mon coeur et mon
carré comme va chuter le mien passe de
60 pulsations minute en surface à moins
de trente pulsations minute en apnée sur
des apnées prolongé avec sa bradycardie
subaquatique se met en place
simultanément une vasoconstriction
périphériques
le sang va refluer de mes membres et se
concentrer sur les organes nobles
nécessaires à la survie qui eux devant
ce vasodilatateur au contraire pour être
le plus oxygéné possible
vraiment de pure mécanisme réflexe de
survie face au milieu alors chez les
mammifères marins c'est un petit peu
plus puissant que chez nous néanmoins
ces réflexes qui sont présents chez tout
le monde peuvent se travailler
s'améliorer avec avec l'entraînement
avec ses deux réflexes très spontanée se
met en place aussi une adaptation un
petit peu plus sur la durée
c'est ce qu'on appelle la polyglobulie
alors c'est un terme médical certains
connaissent peut-être tous les apnéistes
son polyglobulie caisse creek ce terme
nous ça crée ton trop de globules rouges
au niveau sanguin alors sa peau
l'immobilier scène n'est pas
pathologique comme un fumeur ou
quelqu'un turin un problème à moi ce
genre de choses et elle est intéressante
à plus d'un titre déjà principalement
elle améliore le transport de l'oxygène
au niveau sanguin mais en plus de ça
l'apnéiste qui s'entraîne régulièrement
apprend à ses muscles à fonctionner plus
efficacement et plus longtemps avec peu
d'oxygène en hypoxie que ça comme ça en
réalité on s'est rendu compte que la
planète est une sorte de dopage naturel
entre guillemets un peu comme si on
vivait en montagne en permanence de plus
en plus de sportifs censure rendu compte
et leurs le comprennent le réalise
et donc on a de plus en plus de sportifs
de haut niveau aujourd'hui qui intègre
des exercices d'apnée dans leur
préparation physique générale alors j'en
viens à parler de la dernière adaptation
les dernières impact de la pratique de
l'apnée sur sur le plongeur et c'est
pour moi le plus intéressant je pense ce
sont les impacts psychique de ce sport
sur sur sont pratiquement quand vous
êtes sous la surface dans le silence en
apesanteur avec cette sensation de chute
libre de légèreté vraiment qui est là
qui représente totalement coupés du
monde extérieur
de son agressivité de son stress de ses
dangers c'est en plus vous ajoutez à
cela le lait fort mental la gymnastique
mentale qu'impose l'apnée dans le fait
de dépasser cette envie de respirer
le tout en plus avec ces adaptations
physiologique qui transcende en quelque
sorte notre condition d'être humain pour
nous rapprocher un peu plus du mammifère
marin quelque part vous englober tout ça
vous pratiquez deux à trois fois par
semaine l'impact en terme d' équilibre
psychique est très fort et arrive très
vite sur les sur les pratiquants donc en
termes de gestion du stress gestion des
émotions meilleur jeu les dix meilleurs
conscience de soi meilleure confiance en
soi ailleurs constant soit meilleure
conscience des autres et monde dans
lequel on vit et ses accès et en gestion
des défis du quotidien d'ailleurs aussi
et ça ça m'amène à ça m'amène à vous
dire que en fait tout cela ne n'arrive
pas sans effort évidemment longtemps
alors je parle de choses très agréables
adaptation de légèreté de flottement de
contact avec les éléments de la vie sur
mars est arrivée dans tout ça évidemment
vous l'aurez vous l'aurez compris rien
avis arrive sans effort et en
l'occurrence rennes arrive sans prise de
risque sans prise de risque et
potentiellement les échecs qui vont avec
et dans un sport extrême
les accidents éventuels qui peuvent
aussi arriver alors les accidents en
apnée y en a eu des accidents graves
on a tous seuls on a tous en noir en
mémoire de nos camarades qui
malheureusement ont disparu et seront
pas nombreux je vous rassure mais y en a
eu en tout cas ça nous a au moins permis
d'affiner nos systèmes de sécurité de
d'être au top niveau aujourd'hui la
planète un sport très sûr que ce soit au
niveau 1 niveau de loisirs si on
respecte en tout cas les quelques règles
de sécurité de base obligatoire dont la
première est de ne jamais plonger seul
message ou leur ai dit je vais plonger
seul toujours accompli
et de quelqu'un qui est formé pour
pouvoir vous secourir en cas de en cas
de pépin
tout ça pour dire que le l'heureux réel
moyen de d'arriver à tout cela c'est à 2
de conscience c'est de prendre des
risques allant responsable de l'échec
évidemment l'échec gelé connu par
exemple en 2014
j'ai connu ce qu'on appelle une année
blanche j'étais pas bien au niveau de
deux niveaux de montage j'avait j'avais
pas mal de soucis perso dans ma vie
privée donc j'ai pas ramené de médaille
cette année un prix de 14 à la france
j'ai tout de suite et en tout cas
identifiés et accepter ce cet échec est
sûre j'ai continué à m'entraîner
évidemment l'année suivante le revenu
infiniment plus fort en réalité que ce
que j'étais avant là j'ai compris que le
dicton ce qui ne nous tue pas rend plus
fort qui peut paraître un petit peu
surfait s'applique est totalement
légitime et pertinent en termes de
développement personnel je les ai
compris ce jour là et j'en viens
d'ailleurs à à vous conseiller
évidemment de vous fixer des objectifs
alors ces objectifs ont été pour moi
sportif ça a été de tenter de battre des
records d'apnée mais pour ils peuvent
être pour vous professionnels sociaux
financiers que c'est chouette de d'aller
demander une augmentation à votre patron
ça fait de courir un marathon en moins
de 3h pareil de lancer une start-up
d'avoir votre diplôme ça peut être
d'aller parler à la à la jolie blonde à
la machine à café à la pause info speedy
importe en réalité le important est de
se fixer des objectifs et de emprunter
les chemins qui mènent le plus
régulièrement possible avec le plus
d'assiduité possible alors évidemment ne
vous fixez pas d'objectifs dont les
domaines dans lesquels vous êtes
compétent de manière innée je dirais
avec ses vous importe de savoir qui va
secouer la vinaigrette le mieux possible
essayez de quand même de vous fixer des
objectifs quoi
et si de surcroît en plus cette façon
individuelle que vous auriez apprise
peut-être sous la surface d'ailleurs si
jamais s'attendre que certains tentent
encore de sa s'inscrire dans un club
d'appeler de découvrir ces disciplines
mais encore une fois peut-être aussi
derrière votre bureau d'études vous ou
sur le chemin vers le bureau de votre
patron voir ou d'un sommet où je serai
pas aussi c'est tout cela avec quelques
quelques vertus quelques quelques
moralité pour l'intégralité de notre
espèce et la planète sur laquelle nous
vivons qui est qui et où feu de plus en
plus donc je terminerai sur sur ces mots
si c'est vous des objectifs
engagez-vous sur les chemins qui mènent
le risque ne serait il pas d'ailleurs de
ne pas suivre ces chemins de se
retrouver à 40 45 50 ans et regarder
derrière soi les regrettés regretter ce
qu'on n'a pas fait donc prenez ces
chemins les i et tenter tous surtout
votre votre exploit personnel sortez de
votre zone de confort le plus le plus
régulièrement possible et surtout
n'oubliez pas de respirer
merci
[Applaudissements]